when our combination of pandemic related
supply chain problems and the closing of
a big manufacturer's plant has led to a
major shortage of baby formula in the
united states in recent weeks it's
become so severe that president biden
has launched operation fly formula to
import supplies or one of the foreign
companies stepping in is the
family-owned british company kendamille
and joining me now is will mcmahon he's
kendra mills commercial director welf
welcome to you uh for for people who
haven't necessarily been up to speed
with this i mean this is basically being
caused by a big product recall in the us
absolutely and i mean the most immediate
issue is of course what has happened to
abbott which is 48 market share in the
u.s they have had to do a widespread
recall and as you've mentioned covert
disruptions haven't helped but the real
problem the structural problem that has
caused this crisis in the u.s is one of
concentration for the world's biggest
consumer country the top four companies
still control over 90 percent of the
supply of formula and believe it or not
in the uk that was a situation that also
existed
not too long ago before kendamil's
arrival uh into the uk you had a
situation similarly where two brands
control 80 percent of the market so
for such an essential
source of nourishment for children it's
it's frankly it's it's something that
shouldn't exist and we find that parents
really want that choice and they want
modern challenger brands they can step
up and fill that gap and that's what
kendall miller here to do
and how much formula do you hope to be
able to ship to the us
well ian we're going to begin
immediately
hopefully air freighting product as soon
as next week the open window for a brand
like ours to help parents in the u.s
runs until november and we hope to
produce up to two million cans of
product specifically to help parents in
need over in the states but what i
should also add of course is that we are
now the fastest growing brand in the uk
we've got a huge consumer base across 6
000 stores in in britain and our
priority of course will be to ensure
that first we maintain supply for our
parents who rely on us here we're very
fortunate to have a factory that's at
just 50 of its capacity so this was a
human tragedy we wanted to step up and
help and and we're very proud to have a
team uh that allowed us to do it
and
to be absolutely clear to pick up on
what you just said that there is no way
that uh uk consumers will will miss out
as a result of this initiative
absolutely not in fact ian we are seeing
900 growth of the kendama brand over the
last two years in the uk and we're
forecasting similar growth going forward
so we have absolutely uh covered for
that capacity and most of the supply
we'll be giving to the us will be gotten
from extra days of production moving
from a five day to a seven day drying
schedule so everything will be
incremental
the us food and drink administration has
very very strict rules indeed about what
uh what can be imported into the us is
that potentially going to be a stumbling
block
well ian it is a stumbling block for
many european brands for kendamil we are
quite unique in that the kendama recipes
sold in the uk are fully nutritionally
compliant with the us and it might
surprise people to know that the u.s
nutritional requirements for baby
formula are not the same as in europe
different iron levels different protein
standards so this is what really
unlocked things with the fda for
kendamil we were able to move very
quickly provide them a product that met
all the nutritional requirements of
course in english language cans
and of course we had a very very good
relationship with the fda over the last
five years we have a 60-year heritage of
making formula here in britain and that
was something that gave them immense
trust in us as a brand and how are you
trading day to day right now apart from
all that are you seeing much of a
pressure coming in from inflation
inflationary inputs
well like everybody in certainly supply
chains are challenged and baby formula
is no exception i think where we have a
unique advantage relative to other
brands say here in the uk where we've
seen big inflation in in in other baby
formula brands is that we have a fully
british supply chain so we've been
shielded from some of the impacts of
certainly brexit but also more recently
covered because we work with local
british farmers we get our oils our way
our vitamins and minerals all from here
in the uk and that has allowed us to
really shield our supply chain and what
it means for consumers is that kendamil
has been able to
actually during this during this period
of inflation we've become even more
competitive for 100 grams versus other
brands
so inflation is certainly real it
affects everybody but we find that
sourcing locally and working with local
suppliers of which the quality is so
high here in britain really helps
all right well good to talk to you this
morning i think i called you will
further on for which i apologize put it
down to old age i need some formula
myself